one half of one percent of all checked
bags go unclaimed or are lost at the
airport and the airlines reunite most of
those bags with their owners eventually
but for those that never make it to
their destination look no further than
the tiny town of scottsboro alabama home
of the unclaimed baggage center
unclaimed baggage center is the only
store in america that buys and resells
unclaimed baggage from the airline
industry we've been doing it since 1970
and you never know what you're going to
find when you walk in the door
the store stocks 7 000 items every day
from its inventory of unclaimed bags and
cargo acquired through decades-long
purchasing partnerships with air
carriers train and bus lines bags are
purchased site unseen employees then
sort through the contents and determine
what to sell clean donate or throw away
and as i discovered it's not as easy as
it sounds
oh
i hope she was a good girl
it's not in fantastic shape it's got a
couple of the ringlets missing anything
that says coke has good resale value
these are her jeans you can tell a lot
about a woman by her jeans
you know she wasn't a great dresser
clothing is dry cleaned on site at one
of the largest dry cleaning operations
in the state of alabama department of
defense protocol is used to clear the
data from electronics various
departments do research online to price
items many high value items come with
appraisal papers but unclaimed baggage
doesn't sell anything online there is
only enough inventory to support a
single brick and mortar location
this has made the store a bucket list
destination for many and a top tourist
attraction in the state
are you from jackson no actually from
california
and how did you find this place we found
it on an app actually that showed us
that this was located nearby so we
thought we'd check it out where are you
guys from michigan
michigan just outside detroit well we're
on our way to san antonio
so we just turn left
the list of unclaimed items discovered
over the years
surprising from moose antlers to
surfboards wedding rings google glass
and a sixty thousand dollar rolex
earlier this year people will travel
with anything but if you're thinking of
making a special trip south to find your
lost bag
think again we have people from time to
time that come in looking for their
items although it's not something we
recommend it's like a needle in a
haystack